[Musica]
che cosa vi fa venire in mente
questa immagine
spaghettate con amici serate a sushi
lungomare cose del genere no sono
abbastanza sicura che però a nessuno di
voi o quasi non verranno in mente le
parole perdita di biodiversità
oppure conflitto ambientale
eppure questa correlazione con i gamberi
esiste vi invito ad andarlo a guardare
perché è davvero molto interessante e si
sa rebbe per un altro talk
ma così come i gamberi
qualsiasi altro oggetto della nostra
quotidianità
potenzialmente potrebbe portarsi dietro
una storia di soprusi o distruzione
ambientale di cui noi magari non
conosciamo nulla e questo perché di
norma il consumatore medio non si
informa non sa bene che cosa sta dietro
a tutto quello che fa ho tutto quello
che compra e anch'io fino a qualche anno
fa avevo solo una vaga idea di come le
mie azioni potessero impattare ori per
ripercuotersi sul pianeta terra
sull'ambiente e sulla società finché non
ho deciso di iscrivermi a geografia in
università
so che tra molti di voi le cose che
saltano in testa sono allora qual è il
fiume più lungo dell'italia allora qual
era la capitale dell'uzbekistan
sequel e geografia ma non è solo questo
quello che mi ha fatto proprio
innamorare di questa materia ed è come
si studiano le correlazioni che guidano
il nostro pianeta e tutto quello che ci
sta intorno
geografia come scienza ponte tra scienze
dure e scienze sociali e quello che ho
capito è proprio che la terra è un
sistema complesso e in questo sistema
esistono tantissimi fattori da fattori
chimici fisici sociali che governano
tutto quello che vediamo e conosciamo
ma cosa c'entra questo con il
cambiamento
c'entra perché questo modo di andare
avanti non è più sostenibile senza
sapere che cosa sta dietro alle cose e
oggi vi voglio proprio parlare di questo
di solito siamo abituati a pensare al
cambiamento come una serie una catena
semplice lineare causa effetto
un po come ci ricorda anche l'effetto
farfalla che quindi parte dal battito
d'ali di una farfalla per arrivare a un
uragano
quello che però non c è sempre chiaro
anzi non consideriamo quasi mai è cosa
sta in mezzo i vari procedimenti i vari
step intermedi che vanno dal punto di
partenza la farfalla al punto d'arrivo
l'uragano
come accennavo già prima il nostro modo
di pensare è basato su una linea come
questa abbiamo un problema cerchiamo un
azione che produrrà un effetto e
arriveremo in qualche modo all'obiettivo
finale
ma anche qui c'è un problema
che cosa succede tra uno step e l'altro
oggi sono qui per dirvi che dalla metà
degli anni 90 una sorta di upgrade di
questo modo di pensare molto meccanico
quasi robotico binario esiste ed è molto
più rappresentativo di come funziona la
realtà e come funzioniamo noi che di
sicuro però meno per ora non siamo
ancora dei robot dei cyborg eccetera
magari tra vent'anni
e questo metodo è stato sviluppato
appunto negli anni novanta per provare a
valutare e progettare meglio degli
interventi di cooperazione all'interno
di contesti sociali complessi
ha tra l'altro parlando di cambiamento
nome molto evocativo
si chiama infatti fear of change ovvero
la teoria del cambiamento ed è infatti
un metodo molto rigoroso molto specifico
preciso ma non rigido che cerca di
considerare proprio quei passaggi
mancanti che di solito diamo per
scontati ma che invece sono fondamentali
per generare cambiamento
e quindi
ci servono tre rivoluzioni almeno per
poter applicare la teoria del
cambiamento alla nostra vita quotidiana
la prima è attenzione all'obiettivo
il nostro obiettivo finale deve essere
l'unica cosa che importa non dobbiamo
fiondarci subito sul pensare a quali
attività a compiere di solito è la prima
cosa che si fa no
pensate a quelle volte che volevate
cambiare qualcosa della vostra vita che
sia a tornare in forma
smettere di fumare imparare una lingua
straniera
abbiamo detto perfetto voglio tornare in
forma da domani solo insalata durato due
giorni perché poi è l'hamburger
hamburger
ed è qui il problema del sistema lineare
che invece la theory of change cerca di
ribaltare l'obiettivo finale è tutto ciò
che conta la seconda rivoluzione
conseguente è proprio l'atteggiamento
nei confronti di questo obiettivo
infatti al posto di scalare una
ipotetica scala degli obiettivi o delle
attività da raggiungere per da attuare
per raggiungere il nostro obiettivo
la tears of change propone di procedere
esattamente come un gambero al contrario
partendo dall'obiettivo e chiedendosi
quali sono le condizioni necessarie per
me per ottenere quel cambiamento per
ottenere quell'obiettivo e quindi
mettiamo caso che
voglio avere una vita più sana mi
chiederò perché io oggi non ho una vita
sana ho uno stile di vita sano e il
motivo potrebbe essere perché non faccia
abbastanza attività fisica
ma perché non faccio attività fisica
perché magari lavoro troppo e quindi non
ho tempo
in questo modo scoprirò che la causa
della mia vita non sana non è che non
mangio insalata tutti i giorni ma
semplicemente non ho tempo per dedicarmi
a certe attività
la terza e ultima rivoluzione che è
necessario compiere è mettere tutto per
iscritto creare una mappa del nostro
cambiamento di quello che vogliamo
raggiungere che non sembrerà come questa
qui che vedete quindi una linea ma
somiglierà molto di più a questo perché
la realtà è complessa e anche se può
spaventare vedere uno schema del genere
voi con le vostre domande quindi i
vostri perché avete trovato le cause
fondamentali che regolano la vostra vita
in questo momento e che vi impediscono
di arrivare all'obiettivo di domani che
vi siete prefissati
questa mappa oltre alle cause poi in se
verrai verranno inserite anche gli
obiettivi che vogliamo raggiungere
e le persone che potranno aiutarci nel
nostro cambiamento
ovviamente
la teoria del cambiamento viene usata
soprattutto in ambiti di cooperazione
quindi da grandi o ng grandi e piccole
realtà dall'onu e ovviamente la loro
teoria del cambiamento è leggermente più
complessa di como cercato di spiegarvi
oggi però i concetti sono sempre quelli
e gli obiettivi le cause che spesso
magari sono difficili da trovare
rimangono sempre alla base del
cambiamento
perché se c'è proprio una cosa sicura in
questo mondo è il cambiamento e se
vogliamo farne parte esserne partecipi
dobbiamo imparare a lavorare ea vivere
nella complessità in cui siamo immersi
quindi la prossima volta che vorrete
cambiare qualcosa della vostra vita per
altri per una causa superiore
provate a ripensare ai nostri amici
gamberi e provate a ripercorrere
all'indietro tutte le varie cause per
scoprire su che cosa lavorare e trovare
quel battito d'ali che scatenerà che
scatenerà uragani di cambiamento grazie
[Musica]